Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
Alzi la mano chi sa
che cos'è una smart city.
Be', vedo che non ci sono
molte mani che si alzano,
per cui questo quarto d'ora
sarà sicuramente di grande utilità.
In effetti, ci sono
tante definizioni di smart city.
E perché questo?
Perché la città è un organismo
molto complesso.
E anche la città intelligente
è molto complessa,
perché ha tante infrastrutture
da connettere fra di loro,
tanti servizi da erogare,
e tanti soggetti
che devono collaborare insieme
per rendere la città
sempre più vivibile e più fruibile.
Ma cosa pensano i cittadini,
della smart city?
Cos'hanno capito, i cittadini,
Abbiamo fatto un po'
di interviste per strada
e le abbiamo raccolte in un video
di cui vi faccio vedere un pezzettino.
[Per te, cosa è una smart city?]
- Che cos'è una smart city?
La smart city è una città
dov'è possibile fare acquisti di servizi,
e utilizzo di beni,
tutto tramite app e cellulare.
- La smart city è una città
che ci deve mettere
in connessione con servizi facili.
- Eh, no: smart city?
Mi prende un po' alla sprovvista.
- Organizzazione
urbana efficiente.
- Oddio, non ne ho idea.
- Non mi viene
in mente. Non lo so.
- Una città piena di tecnologia,
di servizi, il wifi è pubblico,
dove non devi pagare, con il telefonino
puoi fare una serie di attività.
- Fammici pensare
- Allora, smart city: servizi
che si possono utilizzare
sullo smartphone.
- Fondamentalmente,
un'integrazione di vari servizi,
sia tecnologici che rivolti al sociale.
Come vedete, di tutto di più:
chi ha dato una risposta
l'ha data in funzione, soprattutto,
di quello che è il suo modo
di vivere la città
e di come si aspetta che questo modo
possa essere in qualche modo migliorato.
Qual è la mia, la nostra
definizione di smart city?
È una città che mette
al centro il cittadino
e rende l'utilizzo della città
più semplice, più economico,
più sostenibile.
Proprio per dare ai cittadini,
ma anche agli amministratori,
un modo per misurare
quanto è intelligente la propria città,
e scoprire chi ha fatto meglio,
e quindi poter imparare
da chi ha già fatto esperienza,
abbiamo inventato uno Smart City Index,
una classifica di tutte le città italiane
sul livello di intelligenza
che queste città hanno raggiunto,
cioè i servizi che sono, effettivamente,
disponibili nelle città.
E qual è il risultato?
Come vedete, le città sono 116:
sono i 116 comuni capoluogo di provincia
che esistono in Italia.
E la differenza tra le città è notevole.
La prima è Bologna,
considerata molto vivibile;
dopo ci sono Milano, Torino;
ma c'è anche Mantova, una città piccola
che si è resa, ultimamente, molto smart.
All'ultimo posto abbiamo Sanluri.
Immagino che pochissimi di voi
siano stati a Sanluri;
e forse pochi sanno
che è uno dei capoluoghi
ufficiali della Sardegna,
dove abbiamo riscontrato
pochissima innovazione.
Però c'è un sindaco giovane,
molto brillante,
che ha subito chiamato
per far vedere quel che sta facendo
per rendere smart la città,
e che sicuramente lo faranno
salire in classifica.
Dov'è Como?
Al 41° posto.
In posizione media,
senza infamia e senza lode.
Poi vedremo qualche dettaglio in più,
per capire meglio com'è posizionata.
Come costruiamo lo Smart City Index?
E quindi, come cerchiamo
di classificare le città?
Ci mettiamo dal punto di vista
di chi la città la usa.
Cioè cerchiamo di fare
i cittadini virtuali
di tutti i 116 capoluoghi,
e cerchiamo di muoverci nella città,
di studiare, di curarci, di lavorare,
e cerchiamo i modi semplici per farlo.
Andiamo a cercare se ci sono
dei servizi in rete -
o su Internet, sul telefono -
che ci aiutano a fare
queste cose nelle città.
E la stessa cosa la facciamo
mettendoci dalla parte del turista,
che cerca di capire
che cosa c'è di attrattivo nella città,
che cosa ci posso trovare,
dove posso trovare
da mangiare e da dormire,
come posso acquistare in rete
i biglietti che mi servono per visitarla.
Quindi ci mettiamo proprio nell'ottica
di chi la città la usa.
E se troviamo tanti servizi digitali,
mettiamo tanti "+";
se non li troviamo, tanti "-".
E così viene fuori il ranking della città.
Allora, mettiamoci dal punto
di vista del cittadino.
Abbiamo scelto un tema,
che è quello della mobilità.
Cosa vuol dire? Qual è la città
che ha la mobilità più smart?
A noi risulta Genova,
seguita da Torino e Milano;
ma anche Arezzo è pochissimo
distante da Genova,
quindi anche una piccola città
può avere tanti servizi smart.
L'ultima è Campobasso,
dove abbiamo riscontrato
pochissima innovazione;
e Como, qui, è posizionata
un po' meglio della media.
Era 41° nel complessivo
ed è 32° sulla mobilità.
Un pochettino più smart
di quello che è in altri ambiti.
Che cos'è che abbiamo trovato a Genova,
e nelle altre città,
che rende la mobilità smart?
Abbiamo trovato, per esempio,
delle smart card dei trasporti pubblici,
su cui è possibile caricare
biglietti e abbonamenti.
Abbiamo trovato che nei parcometri
si può pagare anche col bancomat,
e con la carta di credito,
o addirittura con una app.
Abbiamo scoperto
che molto spesso è possibile,
quando si è in giro per negozi,
si è a pranzo con degli amici,
si è in una riunione,
e si è vicini alla scadenza
del parcheggio,
invece che scendere di corsa
a infilare le monete
e il biglietto all'interno della macchina,
si va sull'app e si prolunga, banalmente,
di un'ora il parcheggio,
evitando così di muoversi.
Sono città dove il tempo
di arrivo dei mezzi
non c'è solo sulle paline,
che ormai sono diffuse
in tantissime città,
ma si trova anche sul telefono:
per cui, se devo scendere fra tre fermate
e prendere un altro mezzo,
posso controllare se quel mezzo lì
è in ritardo o sta arrivando,
per cui posso decidere
se affrettarmi per prenderlo
o se posso pigliarmela comoda.
Sono città dove troviamo
delle informazioni
molto focalizzate all'utilizzo.
Per esempio, l'ATM a Milano
avvisa via Twitter
sullo stato di funzionamento
delle singole linee.
Per cui, se io tutti i giorni
prendo il tram 16 per andare a lavorare,
preferisco essere aggiornato
non su qualunque mezzo pubblico
che può avere dei problemi,
ma proprio su quel tram lì.
Per cui mi avvisano quando si blocca,
se c'è un percorso alternativo,
e mi avvisano quando
viene ripristinato il servizio.
Così sono in grado di organizzarmi
meglio nel mio spostamento.
Però, la mobilità smart
non è solo il trasporto pubblico:
è soprattutto la riduzione
del trasporto privato,
quella che si chiama "mobilità condivisa".
Ormai, in sempre più città
troviamo il car sharing, il bike sharing.
Addirittura, è stato introdotto in Italia,
tra i primi in Europa, lo scooter sharing!
C'è a Milano e Roma.
È la possibilità di scegliere un mezzo
che non è mio, ma è messo in condivisione;
utilizzarlo per lo spostamento
e per il tempo di cui necessito,
lasciarlo in giro per la città
e continuare a muovermi.
Perché le città puntano molto
sulla mobilità condivisa?
Perché, ad esempio,
uno studio fatto a Milano
indica che le automobili sono utilizzate,
in media, solo 15 minuti al giorno.
Ciò significa che stanno ferme,
inutilizzate e sostanzialmente inutili,
per 23 ore e 45 minuti, tutti i giorni.
Immaginate cosa vuol dire
avere meno auto nella città,
ma più utilizzate, magari in modo
condiviso da più cittadini.
Questi sembrano discorsi utopici.
Però in realtà a Milano, dopo nove
anni in cui sono state introdotte,
piano piano, tutte queste forme
alternative di spostamento,
che danno la possibilità al cittadino
di scegliere modi diversi
con cui spostarsi,
l'effetto è che ci sono
50.000 auto in meno.
Milano è riuscita, con questi mezzi,
a togliere 50.000 macchine
dal parco auto che circola nella città.
Quindi, gli effetti di queste politiche
a lungo andare si vedono.
Addirittura, ci sono delle città
che si sono reinventate
attraverso tecnologie e social network.
Per esempio, questa è
una città spagnola, che si chiama Jun.
Che è piccola, in realtà.
Però si è reinventata, riorganizzata,
attraverso Twitter.
Non solo il Comune ha un account Twitter -
questo ce l'hanno tanti Comuni -
ma tutti i dipendenti comunali
hanno un account Twitter.
Tutti i cittadini hanno un account Twitter
certificato dal Comune
e il Comune e i cittadini
dialogano attraverso Twitter.
I cittadini possono segnalare:
la panchina rotta, il lampione guasto,
il verde mal curato;
il Comune manda una squadra, interviene,
e l'addetto fa la foto, posta
su Twitter e restituisce quindi -
al cittadino che l'ha segnalato,
ma a tutta la cittadinanza -
il segnale che l'intervento è stato fatto.
Questo ha migliorato la comunicazione
fra cittadini e Comune:
i cittadini sono più motivati
a fare le segnalazioni,
e il Comune è spinto a intervenire
nel più breve tempo possibile.
Passiamo adesso al tema
del turismo e della cultura smart.
Qual è la nostra classifica?
Anche qui, vedete,
c'è tantissima differenza tra le città.
La prima è Roma.
Allora, Roma è una città
sicuramente ritenuta problematica,
che i cittadini romani e i visitatori
tendono a considerare
tutt'altro che smart.
Però noi, che analizziamo
con questi parametri molto schematici,
troviamo tanti problemi e inefficienze,
ma anche diverse eccellenze.
E sicuramente, se fossero più conosciute,
i cittadini userebbero
di più questi servizi,
e forse avrebbero
una percezione della città diversa.
L'ultima è, anche
in questo caso, Campobasso.
Ho scelto due casi in cui -
evidentemente, a Campobasso
la gente non si muove,
e non ci son turisti.
E Como dov'è?
Como è curioso,
perché è cinquantaseiesima,
cioè ha una performance
peggiore della media.
Era quarantunesima in generale -
qui cinquantaseiesima.
Poi vedremo perché, su questo
c'è una riflessione da fare.
Che cos'è che ha Roma
di tanto particolare?
Roma ha un sistema online multilingue
per attirare i turisti da fuori.
Cioè si occupa soprattutto di spiegare
cosa è possibile trovare a Roma,
dove si può dormire,
dove si può alloggiare.
E la possibilità di prenotare on line
tutti i musei, una serie di musei,
gallerie e monumenti,
online, prima di arrivare.
Quindi, tanti video,
percorsi personalizzati,
delle app che ti mostrano
cosa puoi visitare
intorno a te nella città.
Cioè, cura molto l'attrattività
nei confronti dei turisti esteri.
Per esempio, ha un'app
che consente di saltare la fila
in alcuni monumenti.
Al Colosseo, c'è sempre
una fila gigantesca alla biglietteria.
Però, anche in tempo reale
io posso, tramite l'app,
fare il biglietto,
mi presento all'ingresso
e mi fanno passare.
Quindi tecnologie che consentono
di facilitare l'ingresso ai monumenti.
Un'esperienza molto interessante
e molto futuribile
è questa della realtà virtuale.
I Fori Romani: ci sono due esperienze
che vengono fatte nelle sere d'estate,
in cui ai visitatori
vengono dati degli occhialini
e attraverso questi si vede il Foro,
ricostruito con la realtà virtuale,
com'era 2.000 anni fa.
E c'è una voce,
che in questo caso
è la voce di Piero Angela,
che racconta cosa succedeva,
come venivano utilizzati questi spazi,
cosa succedeva 2.000 anni fa
e quali eventi storici,
tipo l'uccisione di Cesare,
sono avvenuti in questi luoghi.
Quindi c'è la possibilità di introdurre
tecnologie molto avanzate,
che consentono di andare oltre le rovine -
pur bellissime - che ci sono a Roma.
Il prossimo passo è:
abbiamo detto, cittadino, turista.
Il prossimo passo
è provare a fare il pacco.
Perché anche il tema delle merci,
e dei pacchetti che girano nelle città,
ci sta molto a cuore.
Molte città si stanno muovendo
nella cosiddetta "smart logistics",
cioè la logistica intelligente,
per evitare che i camioncini
girino nella città congestionandola,
e ottimizzando la consegna delle merci.
Chiudo su Como.
Questa è la nostra visione di Como
su tutte le aree che analizziamo
per lo Smart City Index.
Come vedete, la linea rossa
è il punteggio che dà
il posizionamento di Como
per ciascuna area tematica.
Ci sono due eccellenze che ha Como,
in cui il punteggio
è superiore alle altre.
Una è la sanità digitale,
che è tipica un po'
di tutte le città lombarde,
in cui, per esempio, è possibile avere
tutti i dati clinici in rete,
è possibile prenotare online
la visita sanitaria,
è possibile ricevere il referto via email
e pagare, in molti posti,
il ticket online.
Ma anche sulle reti ambientali,
quindi sulla parte che riguarda
le acque, le fognature,
il verde pubblico, i rifiuti,
la performance di Como
è superiore alla media in Italia.
Questi sono i due punti di eccellenza.
I punti, invece,
un pochettino più problematici
sono questi che vedete
col riquadro in rosso:
le reti energetiche.
Sul fronte dell'illuminazione pubblica,
dell'efficienza
e del risparmio energetici,
ci sono città che stanno puntando molto
sulle energie rinnovabili,
per cercare di rendere la città
un luogo dove si consuma meno energia,
e quindi più sostenibile.
Anche sulla parte dell'e-government,
quindi dei servizi pubblici in rete,
molte città stanno spingendo
sui certificati anagrafici online,
sulle pratiche edilizie online,
sull'identità digitale.
Sicuramente, su questo Como
ha un po' da lavorare.
La cosa sorprendente
è il tassello "Turismo e cultura".
Perché Como è piena di turisti,
è molto famosa nel mondo.
Quindi, stupirebbe trovarla qui.
In realtà, è una caratteristica
che abbiamo riscontrato
in molte città d'arte italiane:
in qualche modo, si accontentano
dei turisti che hanno
e quindi si accontentano
di mettere in rete un po' di informazioni,
per far capire cosa si può
vedere nella città.
Magari siti ben fatti,
però molte città stanno scommettendo
molto di più su questo tema.
Perché dovete pensare
che i turisti di domani
sono i giovani di oggi,
che si informano, condividono
e sognano i posti dove andare
su Facebook, su Twitter, su YouTube.
Se una città non si presenta bene oggi -
con tanti servizi,
in maniera molto ricca ecc. -
su questi canali,
rischia che i giovani di oggi
non diventeranno poi i turisti di domani.
Vi lascio quindi con questo compito.
Grazie.
(Applausi)